hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
gonna be reviewing ant-man that's why I
have my marvel shirt on and my Avengers
boxers whew this is my little ant-man
that's not a compliment that's a that's
a horrible thing to say about your penis
you can see I know it's not giving the
audience what they want alright so in
case you guys haven't heard of ant-man
here's the log line from IMDB armed with
a super suit with the astonishing
ability to shrink and scale but increase
in strength con man Scott Lang play by
Paul Rudd must embrace his inner hero
and help his mentor dr. Hank Pym play by
Michael Douglas plan and pull off a
heist that'll save the world now before
I go into this I will let you know that
I'm going to be doing a spoiler review
of ant-man so I'll talk about the
Avengers tie-ins the cameo some Easter
eggs you know the fun stuff for you
comic book freaks but for now this is
the spoiler free review let's get into
this I'll start off by saying this film
is incredibly entertaining it's really
fast paced feels fresh which I'm so
happy to say because when I saw the
trailers for this film I was like yeah
it looks cool but it also looks like a
typical Marvel film it's nice to say
that it feels fresh I mean yes it does
pretty much follow the Marvel beat sheet
of their origin tales like it's a very
similar outline but even with the
villain if you look at Iron Man you went
up against Obadiah Stane which had a
more advanced Iron Man suit the Hulk
goes up against the bombuh nation which
he essentially has the same stuff that
Bruce Banner has Captain America goes up
against Red Skull and Red Skull is a
failed experiment of what Captain
America is now here we get a similar
thing with a villain Darren cross and
the portrayal of him was pretty cliche
I'm hearing that all across the board
and I completely agree it's a very
typical hamming it up the evil type of
performance it's like why is this guy
such a dick I mean then he eventually
becomes yellowjacket which is a more
advanced suit of the AI ant-man suit now
what I will say though despite its
similarities the film still felt fresh
even with the villain I like the fact
that Darren cross is like an older man
with
daddy mentor issues he studied under dr.
Hank Pym he strives to impress the guy
it's like he gets all of his self-worth
based off the opinion of dr. Pym which I
felt actually added a more human
dimension to the villain and it made me
understand his motives like even more
now the number one thing I'm hearing
from like everyone and I totally agree
this film is [ __ ] funny it's
hilarious I laughed a lot of guardians
of the galaxy but this has to be the
Marvel film I cracked up at the most
especially because of Michael Pena cool
Hispanic dude like a lot of the
scenarios are really funny a lot of the
interactions are really funny but
Michael Pena whenever he was on screen
he stole the show just from his first
scene he is the most interesting person
to watch when he is in a scene like I
loved his work over the years especially
in his dramas man like this role was
sort of written like a stupid Latino
low-class kind of guy like it was it
felt like the writing was a little
cliche but his performance made it so
much more unique and the humor to this
film is so important it's a necessity
like it's a lot of it is very self-aware
kind of humor you're dealing with a
story about a hero called ant-man he's a
superhero the size of an ant the writers
knew there was like a silliness to it
and they gladly acknowledge it and
without them acknowledging when it's
funny like when it's something that you
can laugh at a little bit then when they
show you the moments where they want you
to find the power is really cool they
feel really cool I love how it works for
the different types of ants it's very
similar to how I work with all the girls
on this channel excluding Veronica she
whenever she is in the room she is lead
aunt even forms a personal bond with
like a flying an which is [ __ ] cool
balls I'm Antony the montage you see of
him learning how to work the suit was
really funny it was really cool too and
that journey makes you really root for
ant-man the fact that he has to work
with these insects form a connection
with them in order to lead them makes
the dynamics that much more intense
because we see that at first he doesn't
quite get how to do it so yes ant-man
he's [ __ ] awesome but how is Paul Rudd
as Scott Lane a big part of me knew he'd
rocked the role but at the same time
there was a little bit of doubt in the
back of my mind I loved him in most of
his work but as a lead in a Marvel film
I was like I'm not too sure about that
just a little bit I wasn't sure but sure
enough yeah he [ __ ] ruled he was
awesome he's totally believable as his
cat burgler way before he gets to see
you see the kind of skills this guy has
the kind of skills that make some worthy
of the suit that makes him worthy of the
mission like he does bring a lot of that
Paul Rudd charm but it's also one of his
more sincere performances he's usually
in like a state of sarcasm with a lot of
his roles but he delivers his lines with
a lot of sincerity he's sarcastic at the
right moments which made him a total
delight to watch he's a cool theif he's
intelligent he's inventive Paul Rudd
owns this role he's completely
believable in it his character's a thief
so they recruit him to become the
ant-man because of his skills as a thief
hence we get Marvel's first heist film
now I've heard criticisms along the
lines of although it's Marvel's heist
film it pretty much follows the same
structures and rules that a normal high
school would follow so it doesn't have
much new to the heist rendre first off I
disagree with that
I like how they honored a lot of the
heist films and the fact that it's a
Marvel heist film automatically makes it
different because it's a heist film
that's a combination of superpowers as
well to say it's not a unique heist film
is you're being an [ __ ] now this part
of the movie is where I've been hearing
a lot of criticism the relationship
between Paul Rudd and his daughter like
I like this particular storyline sure it
sort of feels like a plot device but it
works that's the important part is that
it adds to the story like it's the
biggest part of his characters
motivation is to just be with his
daughter
so the fact that people are bitching
about this part of the movie gets me a
little upset
you hear me curse stuff and I'm sorry
Kristen I adore you I didn't mean that
Chris way more subscribers like it's
such an essential parts of the story
that to get rid of it would kind of be
an insult like in a lot of ways this is
Marvel's like live-action family film
like with a lot of Marvel films even
Iron Man I can see how parents might be
like even though it's pg-13 is still a
little too
and there's other elements that this is
good for kids this to me even though
it's dealing with a thief it's a total
family film sure there's some bad
language here and there but other than
that it's just so damn enjoyable and
light-hearted like that's another thing
I'm hearing is that oh this Marvel film
isn't as risky as a lot of comic book
films sure but I like the fact of how
it's so light-hearted because that's
just it it has so much heart a big theme
of this movie is family like with
Michael Douglas and Evangeline Lilly
first off Michael Douglas is dr. Hank
Pym Wow to this day he is still one of
the best actors around I loved him in
this role you totally believed him as
his character despite the many Michael
Douglas performances we've seen and
honestly to me his character and his
performance was more interesting to me
to watch more than Paul Rudd's not
saying Paul Rudd's was bad at all I'm
saying that I just I wouldn't mind seen
like a prequel story - when dr. Hank Pym
was ant-man he's complex his way towards
people kind of makes you challenge his
opinion of him the man he is good I
there's not enough words for me to
express how good he is I'll just say
this out of all the supporting
characters in these Marvel films where
they're just you know human beings not
the superheroes he is by far the most
interesting one of them all more
interesting than fan favorite Pepper
Potts
everyone loves Pepper Potts now
Evangeline Lilly this is the one part
where I'm a little back and forth on her
performance like if I have a criticism
it's honestly her now I know there'll be
plenty of people who disagree with me on
this almost every critic I listen to you
that recommended this movie really liked
her performance now I'm not saying I
didn't like her I want to make that
clear before you start writing a mean
comment yeah [ __ ] I'm not saying I
didn't like her I just didn't always
believe her but the times where I really
believed her were her scenes with
Michael Douglas
she plays Michael Douglas's daughter
there's clearly a distance between them
they have that early expositional
dialogue of hi Hank you ever thought of
calling me Dad some [ __ ] like that
but it also adds another human element
to this film and their scenes I thought
were great there is especially one very
moving
that I didn't almost cry but a part of
me was like I'm crying on the inside and
I'm not gonna give it away but there's a
mid-credits scene that involves them and
without the dynamic created in this film
that mid-credits scene would not be as
rewarding as it is not just because it's
a tease at future Marvel films but it's
a great reward for these characters I
mean yeah and that's pretty much where I
could say in a spoiler-free review
ant-man fantastic film one of the best
summer movies I've seen totally go and
check it out it totally got it right
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope because if we
get more followers we can get even more
product placement now you guys might be
asking yourself why does he talk so
openly about product placement did you
guys know that youtubers really make
most of their money off product
placement if you look at some of the
biggest youtubers there's always a
little product placement in there you
might not even notice it I'm here today
to reveal the secrets about what
youtubers really do they make money off
of you watching them so don't skip those
ads people and follow us on our social
networks because it's all about making
money not about the love of film money